i hope you've packed some ice skates for
your next trip out to sea because the
oceans have completely frozen over
what conditions could cause this massive
oceanic freeze
how would this impact other parts of the
planet
and how could this lead to the mass
extinction of life on earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if all our oceans froze
earth has gone through at least five
major ice ages the last peaked about 20
000 years ago and made earth about five
degrees colder than it is today
but even then you wouldn't have seen a
complete surface freeze of all the
earth's oceans
in this scenario that's our starting
point
a few key factors keep our oceans in a
liquid state except for the coldest
parts of the arctic and antarctic
regions
if these factors were suddenly removed
there would be ice
and lots of it
the first factor is the high
concentration of salt
it lowers the freezing point of the
water from zero degrees celsius to minus
2 degrees celsius
another reason is that there is so so so
much of it about 71
of earth's surface is water covered
and about 96 and a half percent of that
is salt water
all that volume means an enormous amount
of heat would need to be removed to
reach freezing temperatures
and don't forget the oceans are
constantly in motion too currents
distribute warmer waters to colder
regions
lastly the earth's crust is the thinnest
under the oceans
a lot of geothermal heat escapes from
the mantle and up into the water
without those i hope you've got
sunglasses because the earth would be a
cold but reflective planet
that's because ice and snow have what is
known as a high albedo
that's the term for how reflective a
surface is
this effect explains how polar ice caps
have helped keep earth's climate
stabilized for millennia
once more than half of the earth is
covered in ice it would reflect enormous
amounts of sunlight
and this would disrupt the planet's
water cycle
that heat from sunlight would no longer
evaporate water
that would mean no more clouds and
without clouds no more rain
but don't celebrate by trashing your
umbrella
rain and snow are vital to all life on
earth
without either the earth would become as
dry as the south pole or even parts of
the sahara
the oceans freezing over would likely
mean mass extinctions of many species of
animals and since the oceans host 80
percent of the planet's biodiversity
this would be devastating
but there are thriving marine ecosystem
in parts of the arctic but
those evolved and adapted that way
the rest of marine life would probably
perish
and all those dead fish below the icy
surface would have a catastrophic impact
on the economic stability of humans
the ice would cut off marine transport
that would eliminate 80 percent of the
global trade by volume
nearly 56 million people working in the
fishing or aquaculture industries would
suddenly be without jobs
and seafood would no longer be a
reliable staple of any diet
no more sushi poke bowls or shrimp on
the bobby
but
all of these consequences would seem
pale in comparison to the fact that it
would be a lot harder for you to breathe
yeah oceans account for between 50 to 85
percent of the oxygen present in our
atmosphere
this is thanks to all those tiny
plankton algae and bacteria that can
photosynthesize
if oceans froze
these would likely die too
and unless you've planted billions of
trees overnight a lot of land animals
and people would suffocate to death
brain freeze
if you manage to be one of the very few
survivors well eventually oxygen levels
could normalize again
but i'm not sure what life would look
like for you on this frozen planet
from boating to kayaking and whale
watching the ocean gives us joy and
sadly
you would no longer experience the
calming effect of looking at the water
you could pick up a fun activity like
kite surfing but
with frozen waves falling would really
really hurt
i wonder what's worse
the oceans freezing or completely
evaporating
well that sounds like a topic
for another
what if
[Music]